bonsoir et bienvenue dans savouregarde
celui qui va passer l'heure avec nous en
direct ce soir c'est vous Jean-François
Cannes bonsoir et merci infiniment
d'être notre grand témoin ce soir
comment en est-on arrivé là c'est le
titre de votre dernier livre aux
éditions de l'Observatoire question sur
une responsabilité collective sur la
montée des extrêmes dans notre pays et
puis avertissement également sur la
progression inexorable de Marine Le Pen
qui si elle arrivait au pouvoir nous
dites-vous et bien conduirait à la
guerre civile on va en parler les mots
sont forts ça mérite une explication
dans la deuxième partie mais on commence
ce soir bien sûr par la 14e journée de
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites peut être la derdeder les
syndicats commencent à entrevoir la fin
du match en tous les cas le sursaut n'a
pas eu lieu dans la rue on va le voir
alors quelle trace laissera ce mouvement
social et quel déboucher peut prendre
désormais la colère grand débat dans un
instant avec nos invités sur ce plateau
avant de retrouver nos affranchis pour
leur parti pris et puis Bourbon Express
bien sûr du jour à l'Assemblée voilà
pour le programme ce soir vous me suivez
Jean-François Kahn ça vous regarde c'est
parti
[Musique]
900 000 personnes dans toute la France
selon la CGT partout les chiffres des
autorités comme des syndicats sont les
plus faibles depuis le début du
mouvement social le 14e round contre la
réforme des retraites avec donc des
allures d'ultime baroud d'honneur alors
quelle trace elle laissera cette
contestation bonsoir Paul Christophe et
merci d'être là vous êtes député horizon
du Nord vous débattez ce soir avec
Adrien Clouet bonsoir et bienvenue
député la France insoumise de
Haute-Garonne à vos côtés Céline
verteleetti qui arrive tout juste du
cortège parisien secrétaire confédéral
de la CGT enfin bonsoir Stéphane zumsteg
ravi de vous retrouver directeur
département politique et opinion à
l'institut Ipsos Jean-François Kahn
évidemment vous êtes libre d'intervenir
dans ce débat sur les retraites vous y
consacré d'ailleurs la première page et
elle est très forte on y reviendra de
votre dernier livre on va commencer par
dresser la bilan le bilan de cette 14e
journée retraite la lutte finale ou au
contraire prologue d'autres combat il a
deux secondes le chrono de Blacko on
l'accueille tout de suite
bonsoir Stéphane blackowski bonsoir
Myriam bonsoir à toutes et tous alors
cette dernière ou pas journée de
mobilisation l'info du jour vous l'avez
donné la mobilisation est en baisse
alors c'est l'info du jour c'est pas non
plus un scoop c'est-à-dire qu'on s'y
attendait un peu d'une part le mouvement
a commencé en janvier donc la lassitude
serait compréhensible et puis surtout
cette manif d'aujourd'hui elle était
calée deux jours avant ce vote qui doit
avoir lieu jeudi à l'Assemblée qui
permettait éventuellement de revenir sur
l'âge de départ à 64 en or comme
finalement on n'est pas sûr que le vote
puisse avoir lieu ben ça enlève un peu
dans le jeu mais enfin ça n'empêche pas
que en tout cas la CGT on reste très
motivé vous voyez ça faisait la Une de
l'humain ce matin pour la CGT la réforme
ne doit pas s'appliquer et donc quand on
a croisé Sophie business matin et ben
nous a raconté la même chose on écoute
la PPL de jeudi elle est en course et
donc les choses vont se passer jeudi
elles ne sont pas jouées et nous
appelons solennellement Yale brune Pivet
a laissé l'Assemblée nationale voter
alors vous savez que depuis le début du
mouvement on guette les divisions entre
les syndicats au sein de l'interditaire
notamment les plus grosses centrales la
CGT la CFDT ben là sur ce point que
faut-il faire face sur la réforme des
retraites et ce qu'il faut continuer
coûte que coûte la lutte et ben on va
dire qu'elle s'est d'été n'est pas du
tout sur la même longueur d'onde que la
CGT c'est Laurent Berger qui s'exprime
moi j'aimerais j'adorerais vous dire que
on est capable de refaire une
mobilisation à 2 millions de personnes
la semaine prochaine c'est pas vrai
parce que les travailleurs et
travailleuses on peut pas leur mentir
ils sont lucides cette réforme a les
malheureusement promulguée et les
décrets 64 ans sont publiés c'est une
réalité bon cela dit une fois qu'on a
pointé cette divergence pour le reste
non ce qu'il faut ce qui est frappant
c'est que l'insert syndical elle elle
reste unie d'ailleurs et la preuve un
peu anticipé puisque fin mai ils se sont
réunis pour justement fixer d'autres
motifs à la Mobil solutions au-delà des
retraites c'est à dire que bon on
envisage déjà un peu la suite donc il y
a toute une liste de revendications
communes sur la négociation c'est des
entreprises l'égalité homme femme c'est
très c'est assez bas c'est assez
complet donc forcément on voit bien que
regarder même dans le communiqué de
l'intercom syndicale de titre dit quoi
retrait la réforme bien sûr on n'a pas
lâché mais aussi des avancées sociales
c'est-à-dire passer à l'étape suivante
finalement de la mobilisation qui
pourrait se poursuivre donc quand on
demande à ce fibiner si c'est la
dernière ben elle se marre en écoute
à chaque manif vous nous posez la même
question
et donc on va décider ensemble des
suites et c'est quand même probable que
il y ait d'autres manifestations au vu
de la situation sociale dans le pays
parce que la colère sociale elle est
énorme notamment en matière de salaire
donc vous voyez bien que là sur ce point
là il y a pas vraiment de division en
intercire syndicale l'auront berger lui
aussi dit que il y a d'autres sujets qui
méritent de se stabiliser la CGT est
tout à fait d'accord parce que
effectivement on pourrait se dire
peut-être que finalement le gouvernement
a gagné la réforme des retraites mais en
tout cas ça veut surtout pas dire que
les syndicats eux ont perdu la bataille
en sorte perdants d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure Laurent Berger était tout fier
de pouvoir sortir les chiffres de
nouveaux adhérents dans son syndicat
plus de 40 000 adhésions nous dit-il en
l'écoute
de retour on a montré notre centralité
sur le monde du travail au sens où les
travailleurs nous font confiance
donc ça met à mal cette théorie qui
s'est développée depuis quelques années
qui consistait à dire et bien vous voyez
ça sert plus à rien les corps
intermédiaires le syndicalisme etc c'est
pas vrai on est là alors c'est peut-être
le paradoxe finalement de cette grande
bataille des retraites c'est que
finalement les syndicats semblent sortir
renforcer d'un conflit qui sont censés
avoir perdu donc du coup on se pose la
question mais l'ont-ils vraiment perdu
ce conflit la réponse de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon
il y a encore un débat qui va avoir lieu
à l'Assemblée nous allons le mener
jusqu'à la dernière minute jusqu'à la
dernière seconde si nous gagnons nous
aurons gagné si nous perdons la lutte
continuera on sent bien que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon aimerait prendre la tête du
cortège des prochaines mobilisations
est-ce que l'Inter syndicale a envie de
l'inviter en tête du cortège ça fera
peut-être partie des sujets de débat ce
soir en effet pour le moment et il a pas
été aux côtés des syndicats battus
batsous dans les cortèges même s'il
était dans toutes les manifestations
c'est l'universeleti je commence avec
vous pour la CGT il est en train de se
terminer ce match en toute honnêteté des
64 ans alors pas tout à fait quand même
parce que comme ça a été dit il faut
quand même pas oublier ce qui va se
passer le 8 juin d'ailleurs tout le
monde en appel à la responsabilité de la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale dans
le détail donc voilà ça c'est une
match est en train de se terminer que
nous le voulions ou non c'est ce qu'il
dit lui-même il est syndicaliste non
mais
alors après ça peut vouloir dire
plusieurs choses quoi qu'il en soit il
faut quand même pas oublier que
aujourd'hui donc il y avait à peu près
un peu plus de 900 000 personnes qui ont
manifesté c'est quand même encore énorme
parce que un mouvement qui a débuté au
moins de l'intérieur c'est la 14e
journée interprofessionnelle nationale
ça veut dire que pour certains et
certaines ça fait aussi c'est une
journée de grève ça veut dire que c'est
au moins 14 jours de grève puisqu'ils
secteurs professionnels il y a eu encore
plus de grève donc c'est quand même
énorme alors vous comprenez bien que
nous on va pas vous dire aujourd'hui
après toute cette mobilisation après
finalement autant de personnes qui sont
venues nous voir d'ailleurs Laurent
Berger a raison même pour notre
organisation syndicale plusieurs
salariés ou autres viennent nous voir et
veulent ce syndiquer donc après cette
mobilisation qui est inédite et
historique vous comprenez bien qu'on va
pas dire bah écoutez maintenant tout est
fini chacun entre chez soi et on repart
comme avant parce que on attend juin
puis l'Inter syndical se réunit
très régulièrement vous l'avez dit aussi
tout à l'heure très justement nous
sommes en train de travailler sur un
cahier revendicatif c'est-à-dire que
nous allons chercher la des avancées
sociales et bien évidemment notamment
sur des préoccupations qui sont quand
même des préoccupations première pour
les salariés et pour aller les chercher
il va falloir d'une part qu'on discute
ensemble qu'on pose cette plateforme
revendicative unitaire et qu'on aille la
chercher par des mobilisations aussi
parce que c'est bien comment ça marche
que ça soit du côté patronal ou côté
gouvernemental lorsqu'on veut obtenir
des choses concrètes et conséquentes il
faut qu'on soit dans la rue et en grève
et dans la bataille Adrien Chloé puisque
vous étiez tous les deux dans les
cortèges sur l'essentiel c'est un échec
non non les 64 ans ça semble très
compliqué les les décrets sont en train
d'être publiées certains d'entre eux le
sont déjà c'est-à-dire qu'on a un mot
d'ordre qui était refus de la promotion
de la loi et on passera à la lutte pour
labrogation ça ne change rien sur la
revendications tel existe on a le
rendez-vous jeudi donc jeudi on mène la
première étape de la lutte visant
abroger la loi telle qu'elle existe
maintenant on me fera feu de tout bois
sur absolument tous les moyens qui
existent au niveau parlementaire pour
obtenir son abrogation et ça on va le
faire aujourd'hui il y avait quand même
une mobilisation qui était belle il y
avait d'ailleurs des beaucoup de
pancarte qui était assez inventive et
astucieux j'ai beaucoup aimé et 900000
personnes qui tiennent encore la lutte
six mois après le début d'un combat
alors que certaines et certains ont
perdu jusqu'à un mois de salaire au
total c'est un additionne tout moi je
trouve ça extraordinaire
c'est beaucoup par exemple c'est quand
même plus que le nombre de gens qui ont
voté pour votre partie au législatives
alors
je vous propose tout de suite et je me
tourne vers vous pour la majorité dans
un instant bah de les entendre ces
manifestants c'est un sujet d'Hélène
Bonduelle dans le cortège parisien avec
Marion de vauchelle vous allez voir ils
sont pas résignés pas tous mais ils sont
surtout inquiets sur nos institutions et
sur le respect de la démocratie regardez
reportage
64 ans c'est oui ou c'est
Nordine
au bout de 14 quel regard vous portez
sur toute celle que vous avez bon
celle-là c'est la fin quoi la guerre des
Dr le baroud d'honneur peut-être un peu
pour certains aujourd'hui mais pas pour
les plus motivés c'est hors de question
d'arrêter de manifester et les dernières
déclarations de la CFDT d'aujourd'hui
qui serait le dernier rassemblement
c'est pareil c'est hors de question on
va continuer à manifester on va
continuer à méditer je trouve ça beau de
voir qui est autant de gens qui soient
toujours là et qui continuent à y aller
et il faut pas lâcher même si je
honnêtement je sais pas ce que ça va
donner la réforme des retraites est
piliers pour ces femmes il y a d'autres
combats il y en a
il y a des choses qu'on aurait dû
travailler avant et on veut on veut le
faire notamment les salaires les
conditions de travail la reconnaissance
de la pénibilité maintenant faut s'y
mettre on peut le faire il faut que ce
gouvernement il change de paradigme et
qui nous écoutent dans le cortège
parisien qui symboliquement passait
devant l'Assemblée nationale il faut
laisser
le combat était avant tout démocratique
passé en force devant presque tous les
actifs tous les syndicats
tous les groupes d'opposition avec le
49-3 à 47 article 40 je passe on peut
pas dire raisonnablement que c'est la
démocratie ça pour l'instant
présentant du peuple que sont les
députés
donc ce que je
je souhaite mieux et que ce soit les
députés qui votent avec un peu de chance
on se dit que ça peut aussi esquisser
quelque chose pour l'avenir pourquoi par
exemple une offre politique qui soit en
faveur des droits et pas juste pas juste
une répétition d'alternance politique
qui qui fait que mon pote et bon 5 ans
après on subit tu as voulu faire sans
nous juste en
alors Paul Christophe vous les entendez
ces manifestants bon certains ne sont
pas résignés ils veulent continuer donc
la page n'est pas complètement tournée
des retraites mais ce qui revient c'est
beaucoup la question de la confiance
dans les institutions et la démocratie
vous n'avez pas le sentiment avec tout
ce qui s'est passé le 49-3 bien sûr et
peut-être l'article 40 très probablement
qui rendra irrecevable cette proposition
de loi jeudi d'avoir nourri cette
défiance avec cette crise des retraites
en soi on peut pas laisser dire qu'il
n'y a pas eu de vote à l'assemblée
d'abord il y a eu des votes au Sénat il
y a eu le vote en commission mixte
paritaire nous y étions pas à l'assemblé
il y a eu à l'Assemblée nationale nous
avons une commission mixparitaire en
chers collègues nous n'entend pas vous
avez fait en sorte
une notion de censure soit l'expression
des parlementaires contre la réforme
jusqu'à preuve du contraire il y a bien
eu un vote à l'Assemblée nationale sur
ce sujet mercredi dernier nous avons
voté je suis désolé
nous étions bien à l'Assemblée nationale
l'article
on peut pas laisser dire non plus qu'il
y a un absence de démocratie
de la stratégie de procédure dans tout
ça franchement vous savez très bien que
d'une part il y a pas de majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale donc fatalement on
doit se référer aux outils à disposition
c'est de la Constitution le 49
malheureusement il s'applique sur les
budgets puisque par définition une
opposition est là pour s'opposer du
budget donc lorsque pas de majorité vous
ne pouvez avoir recours qu'au 49-3 mais
il y a des choses très intéressantes
comme ils ont dit tout à l'heure parce
que je suis pas sûr moi qui est de
gagnant perdant dans cette histoire en
soi ce que j'observe quand même c'est
qu'il y a une vraie volonté d'être unie
pour aller chercher du progrès social et
des éléments de langage de dire que
personne n'est vaincu personne n'a gagné
à la fin les 64 ans voilà
et puis ceux qui voulaient le retrait
n'ont pas ce qu'il voulait ce qu'on a
voulu sauver c'est quand même le régime
de retraite par répartition d'ailleurs
d'autres nous avons nous l'ont fait je
rappelle simplement que il y a un autre
régime par était partition en France qui
régime agir Carco la retraite
complémentaire des salariés du privé
alors quitte à la main et qui est bien
géré d'ailleurs pas le patrona et les
syndicats je vous rappelle juste qu'il y
a 3 ans la décision était prise de
repousser l'âge de la décote à 63 ans et
de jeûner pourquoi pas pour se faire
plaisir parce qu'il y avait la même
question démographique que celle qui
s'impose à nous je rappelle simplement
que lorsque la retraite par répartition
était mise en place il y avait quatre
cotisants pour un retraité aujourd'hui
c'est 1,7 aucun regret donc sur la
méthode forcément toujours des regrets
en méthode quand on arrive à un nombre
de manifestations comme celle-là c'est
qu'on n'a pas été bon au départ mais
j'ajouterai quand même que on a un
besoin impérieux de faire évoluer les
questions notamment pour la par rapport
à la protection des salariés notamment
sur les questions de pénibilité je pense
à un sujet majeur qui ne pouvait pas
rentrer dans un texte tel qu'on a
proposé puisque c'est un texte
budgétaire et ça c'est un regret quand
même parce que je pense que les deux
auraient dû être mis sur la table
d'emblée et j'ajouterai simplement que
c'est pas 62 ans qu'il faut s'inquiéter
de l'état de santé du travailleur c'est
bien en amont à 50 ans et je pense très
bien
du travail
dans l'ordre on verra on n'a pas de
calendrier pour le moment et l'opinion
est-ce qu'elle les Français il la tourne
cette page ou pas franchement Stéphane
pas après les chiffres de participer de
mobilisation en baisse aujourd'hui
montre bien que pour une partie des gens
même si majorité des Français et des
françaises restent en colère malgré tout
ils ont intériorisé le fait que cette
loi allait passer et le fait même que la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale est
décidait de dégainer l'article 40
quelque part dévitaliser en partie cette
journée en partie ça non parce que
malgré tout il y a eu vous avez raison
de souligner 14 journées de mobilisation
donc le soutien n'a jamais faibli mais
on se retrouve là juste avant goûter
certains sondages je vous interroge sur
le soutien et je vous laisse poursuivre
ça c'est moins important un peu moins
important 55% j'ai pris un lin de vos
confrères à risque interactive estime
que la mobilisation doit continuer donc
c'est moi qu'avant mais en même temps
c'est très très haut encore l'opposition
voulait dire au projet de réforme bien
sûr en mouvement parce que c'est c'est
ce péché originel en tout cas que les
Français opposaient la réforme
reprochent au gouvernement et président
de la République c'est d'avoir mis
d'avoir essayé de faire passer d'avoir
fait passer une réforme qu'il juge
inutile et injuste
tout de même que c'est fini je pense que
oui maintenant ils le savent évidemment
que il y aura le bar où d'honneur
d'aujourd'hui il y aura le vote enfin le
peut-être le débat dans deux jours mais
pour une partie d'entre eux c'est
terminé avec cette idée peut-être non
pas d'organiser une sorte de revanche
sociale ou politique mais en tout cas de
ne pas laisser les choses en l'état et
de et de faire payer quelque part pour
parler franchement au gouvernement et
surtout au président de la République
quelque chose qui n'est pas une
forfaiture c'est pas ça ce serait
exagéré mais quelque chose je répète de
profondément injuste et vous parliez
tout à l'heure de déni de de démocratie
ce qui a fondamentalement changé c'est
que et c'est pour ça que la contestation
reste très forte c'est dans l'esprit des
Français les institutions politiques de
la 5ème République sont arrivés à bout
de souffle dans le sens où tout
fonctionner pour eux quand il y avait
une alternance gauche droite gauche et
ainsi de suite il y avait deux blocs là
on est dans une situation inédite ou un
président de la République a été réélu
facilement presque brillamment mais ne
dispose pas quelques semaines après de
la majorité absolue et ça c'est quelque
chose qui pour les Français
à contribué à se dire que finalement
Emmanuel Macron ne pouvait pas faire ce
qu'il voulait s'il avait été s'il
disposait de la majorité absolue il
aurait eu des contestations évidemment
ça n'aurait rien changé à la
mobilisation dans la rue mais il y
aurait pas eu ce sentiment d'injustice
ou de Béni de démocratie les
institutions ne sont plus faites pour la
situation actuelle on le voit bien dans
les enquêtes trois Français sur 4
estiment que la démocratie est en
mauvaise santé le couple exécutif est en
baisse même si sur la dernière période
il faut quand même le souligner il y a
un léger regain dans l'opinion
Jean-François Kahn je voulais regarder
vous faire intervenir par rapport à
votre livre vous avez c'est le début du
livre des mots très très durs sur le
49.3 on sait que sur le traité
constitutionnel par exemple 2005 vous
avez considéré que ne pas tenir compte
de la vie du peuple français était une
faute et là est-ce que ce serait pareil
parce que je vous cite l'histoire
retiendra écrivez-vous que c'est le
jeudi 16 mars peu avant 15h que fut
déclenché sur un coup de dés le le
processus annonciateur de la
déliquescence puis du lent écroulement
du pouvoir macronien à ce point vous
pensez que c'est un une date charnière
oui mais j'ajoute une chose qui est
importante c'est que ça s'est traduit
aussi par une dédicace pour les autres
et que ce qui est extrêmement inquiétant
c'est la généralisation de ces
déliquescentes c'est-à-dire qu'on sait
qui perd mais personne ne gagne c'est là
où il y a une hypothèse extrême
d'extrême droite bon
là il y avait beaucoup moins de
manifestants moi je pense que gonfler
trop le nombre de manifestants comme le
fait souvent la CGT c'est
contre-performant c'est normal
d'augmenter moi-même j'ai organisé une
manifestation contre la guerre d'Irak
j'ai un peu augmenté non de manifestants
des gens n'y croient plus vous voyez si
vous dites 600 000 alors qu'un absent
mille les gens disent donc les gens n'y
croient plus donc c'est pas un conseil
mais sur le 49 donc 49 3 c'est un peu ce
qu'on paye donc
c'est un échec relatif cette
manifestation je crois qu'il fallait pas
la faire il devait pas la faire mais on
ne peut pas oublier en effet qu'il y a
un mécontentement majoritaire et qu'il y
a eu des manifestations très puissantes
qui n'ont pas fait 4 millions de
manifestants mais même s'ils ont fait un
million et demi c'est énorme c'est
quelque chose de très puissant moi je
crois que des erreurs ont été commises
en particulier alors c'est pas metté par
les insoumis il y a une chose il y a eu
un vote lequel vous faites référence
auquel il aurait pu y avoir
il aurait pu on allait avoir un vote à
l'assemblée je pense que la loi aurait
été refusée à trois fois près et les
intérêts c'est les insoumis qui l'ont
empêché ça ça restera dans l'histoire
des romans où il y allaient avoir un
vote qui allait refuser à quatre voix
près la loi les insoumis d'abord ont
donné une mauvaise image de même parce
que
l'Assemblée sur l'article qui n'a pas pu
être débattuce où tout le monde a hurlé
c'est de sa femme terrible terrible mais
en plus du coup il y a pas eu de vote et
donc la loi n'a pas été rejetée Adrien
Clouet vous pouvez répondre là-dessus au
fond pas de vainqueur que que des que
des perdants y compris dans le camp de
la de la gauche et des insoumis on va
dire au syndicat parce qu'au fond chacun
a empêché à sa façon un véritable vote
sur l'article 7 oui deux éléments de
réponse le premier c'est que je ne suis
pas sûr que les élections partielles le
confirment cette analyse là mais il va
falloir voir les moments qui arrivent
c'est à dire que les scrutins lorsqu'ils
les gens votent ne confirment pas
totalement
la dernière qu'il y a eu était très
mauvaise pour les insoumis elle était
bonne pour les socialiste anti insoumis
oui mais on arrive au stade où on arrive
au stade où les seconds tours des
élections il y a ni le RN ni les
macroniste ce qui est quand même un fait
politique assez marquant et le deuxième
élément c'est que durant le début de la
séquence des retraites moi je reste
convaincu que s'il y avait eu un vote
rapide d'abord moi je ne crois pas qu'il
aurait été
gagnant pour notre camp je ne le pense
pas mais c'est un sujet de discussion je
ne pense pas parce que les coûts de
pression qui ont eu lieu sur les députés
LR ou sur différents autres députés
viser clairement à acheter des voix
viser clairement à modifier les
comportements électoraux des uns des
autres je ne pense pas qu'on est en
train de nous dire qu'on est sorti du
cadre démocratique parce que les mots de
Mélenchon aujourd'hui sont très forts
nous sommes en train de sortir du cadre
démocratique j'arrive tout de suite et
je pense qu'il fallait pour permettre à
la lutte de s'inscrire dans la durée en
fait si on avait bouclé un vendredi soir
cette histoire de retraite avec une
victoire des macronistes on aurait eu
droit à 48 heures de matraquage
médiatique nous disant c'est adopter
c'est fini rentrer chez vous moi je
crains ça et je pense que du coup la
tâche politique qu'on avait c'était de
créer le cadre propice à cette bataille
qui du coup nous a conduit au moment
actuel qui est tout même un moment où
effectivement on a un problème là-dedans
la Cinquième République qui a un
problème initial le coup d'état
permanent c'est pas d'aujourd'hui mais
les institutions jusqu'à présent étaient
utilisées avec un certain degré de
souplesse par des dirigeantes et des
dirigeants qui accordent une place aux
oppositions quelle politique syndical
etc désormais ce n'est plus le cas et
vous évoquiez mercredi dernier la
commission était quand même très
révélatrice de ce qui s'est passé trois
choses rapides premièrement vous avez
chassé les journalistes une première
c'est n'est jamais arrivé les
journalistes qui sont présents en
commission soit chassés pour ne plus
pouvoir entendre ce qu'il disait
que la Commission était était publique
deuxième point c'est la première fois de
l'histoire de la 5e réplique une
présidente de commission décide de ne
plus accepter d'amendement on ne sait
pas d'où la Constitution garantie au
parlementaire le droit d'amender vous
avez refusé oui mais l'amendement est
compris dans le droit à Sousa mangez
seulement y compris dans le droit
d'amendement donc vous avez ça a été
décidé par le bureau de la commission
des affaires sociales de faire tomber
les sous un moment elle a fini par le
réunir et ensuite elle a réuni un bureau
pour obtenir validation de sa décision
personnelle c'est très différent et
enfin terminé parce qu'on a eu ce débat
vraiment le jour J la commission
importante je termine très vite vous
avez l'article 40 d'une manière qui est
là aussi tout à fait inédite puisque
vous rendez re capable des textes sous
prétexte il coûteraient de l'argent
d'abord je ne vois pas en quoi ça coûte
de l'argent d'un projet quelque chose
qui n'a pas d'effet et surtout
deuxièmement lorsque ça vous concerne
vous je pense au texte bien vieillir 8
milliards d'euros là la macronie
s'octroi le droit d'effectuer ce qu'elle
refuse de l'opposition donc ce ballon
vous mettez sur les oppositions demain
il s'appliquera à vous et à votre droit
de liberté en tant que parents la
proposition de douane la recevabilité le
maillon il y a quand même le groupe
liote il faut le rappeler c'est Charles
de Courson il y a une tribune importante
aujourd'hui dans le monde qui dit bien
que à nouveau déni de démocratie ne
pourrait susciter qu'une désaffection
aggravée pour nos institutions c'est
signé Charles de Courson et son groupe
ça n'est pas la gauche de la gauche qui
défendait à 65 ans
c'est que en effet le 49-3 peut avoir
des conséquences mais la preuve en est
que aujourd'hui encore ce qu'on entend
partout et qui joue en faveur du Front
national à un point extraordinaire c'est
ce déni de démocratie qui a été le vote
sur la Constitution européenne on
imagine pas à quel point moi je voté oui
donc je peux en parler mais les gens
votent non vous pensez que c'est de même
nature aujourd'hui non nettement ça n'a
pas empêché qu'on applique la loi qu'ils
avaient refusé sans leur demander leur
avis encore aujourd'hui ça fait des
dégâts en faveur d'extrême droite
d'ailleurs absolument comparable vous
mettez les deux événements du même type
que vous l'avez dit il y a un problème
de la Cinquième République Monsieur
Christophe parce que là c'est important
si on est à ce moment la charnière c'est
c'est au fond tout bénéfice pour Marine
Le Pen je relève quand même c'est que
notre collègue vient d'avouer que ils
avaient comme vous aviez comme peur
d'aller au vote tout en montant dans le
vote puisque vous avez embolisé les
débats avant l'article 7 de peur de le
perdre je prends le point et je vous
l'accorde ce que ce que vous dites par
contre sur le démocratie ce que dit
Charles de Courson je m'inscris comme
info oui certains auraient préféré qu'on
a une sorte qu'on dégaine l'article 40
pour empêcher l'examen la proposition
loi de Charles de Courson en commission
la présidente s'y refusait et je trouve
que ça tout à fait normal puisque ça
aura été effectivement une forme de
bâillon par rapport aux propositions et
plus aucune proposition de loi émanant
d'un parlementaire on aurait pu être
discuté c'était un bon sens par contre
ne confondront pas avec l'application de
l'article 40 au titre des amendements
qui peuvent être déposés et qui
constituent une charge je suis assez
surpris que Charles de Courson utilise
également puisqu'il a défendu cette
règle pendant on en est au cinquième ou
6e mandat d'ailleurs hier soir en
commission c'est sur toutes les
propositions de loi dès lors les
amendements on n'est pas là sur la même
lecture la proposition de loi
ont bien saisi la nuance elle a été
dument débattue en commission la semaine
dernière l'article 1 a été effectivement
repoussé vous l'avez précisé et c'était
bien le preuve que nous avons examiné le
texte donc il n'a pas subi l'article 40
je suis désolé par contre effectivement
ira sur l'amendement qui rétablirait les
64 nous sommes à déposer les amendements
et c'est le droit parlementaire nous
l'exercerons et évidemment ils sont
examinés au titre de l'article pour la
constitution de charge on est bien sur
un schéma complètement différent alors
on va parler de ce qui peut se passer
jeudi dans un instant parce que les
Français nous
le demande il était le conseiller de
Madame Pécresse et c'est lui qui lui a
conseillé la retraite à 65 ans
la retraite à 65 ans écoutez c'est c'est
là
incroyable mais ça c'est le mouvement
social fait toujours du bien à tout le
monde alors j'aimerais connaître on
parlait des vainqueurs et d'évacus avant
d'aller sur ce qui se peut se passer
jeudi
l'opinion est-ce qu'elle elle crédite
les syndicats d'avoir été unis dans dans
ce mouvement on entend parler de de
dizaines de milliers d'adhésion ça c'est
très nouveau c'est nouveau mais ça
confirme ce que disait tout à l'heure
Stéphane blackovski en guise de
préambule il y a un côté paradoxal les
syndicats pour l'instant en tout cas
n'ont rien obtenu pourquoi parce que eux
aussi avaient mis comme comme préalable
le retrait de cet de ce report à 64 ans
donc à partir de là le dialogue était
impossible mais c'est vrai que même si
n'ont rien pour l'instant obtenu ils
sortent un petit peu renforcé dans
l'opinion parce qu'il faut ils viennent
de loin quelque part les organisations
syndicales la France je vous apprends
rien évidemment il y a très peu de
syndicats en France le taux de
participation lors des élections
professionnelles et bien plus bas que
dans d'autres pays et très longtemps une
partie des Français y compris une partie
des salariés ont un peu douté de
l'intérêt de l'utilité surtout le
secteur privé des organisations
syndicales tout ça a changé
parce qu'ils ont su parce que vous avez
su gérer avec beaucoup de doigtés les
différentes journées de mobilisation
parce qu'il n'y a pas eu de débordement
de la part enfin dans les cortèges en
tout cas syndicaux et surtout parce que
l'opinion a aucun moment ne s'est des
jugé et dès le début massivement à
soutenu ce mouvement donc oui quelque
part ils en ressortent renforcés mais
renforcés en termes d'image et
uniquement en termes d'image pas en
terme de puissance
qu'allez-vous faire de cette bonne image
auprès des Français de ce regain
adhésion est-ce que vous allez rester
unis pour aller au-delà des retraites
sur quoi précisément ou au contraire on
sait que la CGT qui est partie donne
plutôt d'une ligne plus radicale va dire
transformons cette lutte dans d'autres
colères peut-être plus local ou en
fonction d'activité économique
particulière non mais il y a pas que
l'image vous avez certainement raison
mais nous ça se concrétise aussi ce
n'est pas qu'une qu'une image que nous
avons renforcé parce que par exemple
lorsqu'on fait des syndiqués et nous
c'est pareil on n'a jamais fait autant
de syndiqués ça se transforme en force
organisée au sein des entreprises et au
sein des lieux de travail pour après
très concrètement justement obtenir des
avancées des par exemple des
augmentations de salaire des meilleures
conditions de travail parce que nous si
vous voulez l'image en quelque sorte bon
ben voilà c'est peut-être important mais
ce que nous voulons quand nous nous
battons comme on le fait et de
différentes manières c'est obtenir des
choses vous l'avez dit lorsque vous avez
des salariés des privés d'emploi des
retraités qui sont dans la rue qui font
grève qui perdent d'ailleurs un salaire
c'est pas juste pour pour voilà manière
de dire voilà on est on n'est pas
content peut-être mais à un moment donné
bien évidemment qu'on va obtenir des
choses très concrètes donc là vous
l'avez dit on voulait oui le retrait de
la réforme des retraites mais parce que
au départ quand même le gouvernement a
refusé justement d'entendre les
organisations syndicales je le dis et je
le précise nous avions des propositions
notamment sur le financement nous
n'avons pas été entendu donc ça nous les
avons porté ces propositions de
financement la durée de cotisation
écoutez ce gouvernement il n'écoute
personne de toute manière c'est comme ça
est-ce qu'elle vous écoute davantage je
sais qu'il y a eu des réunions
bilatérales
vous l'avez dit nous ce que nous voulons
c'est continuer au niveau national en
unité syndicale ça c'est très clair au
niveau des entreprises aussi nous
voulons justement travailler ensemble
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure nous
avons une plateforme revendicative nous
revendiquons des choses très précises
des augmentations de salaire des des
améliorations de conditions de travail
une force de frappe très clairement et
bien évidemment que nous allons utiliser
pour obtenir mais cette bataille là elle
va se
en tout cas on va l'amener à différents
niveaux vous l'avez dit il y a un niveau
national il y a un niveau aussi au
niveau de l'entreprise et ce qu'on nous
demandons précisément à la CGT c'est des
négociations tripartites parce que il y
a des revendications que nous devons
traiter et avec le gouvernement et avait
le patronat ça nous y tenons
particulièrement normalement c'est en
cours il y a des chats des choses qui
sont voilà dans des agendas on verra ce
que ça donne on va terminer ce débat
avec les deux députés à quoi peut-on
s'attendre jeudi théoriquement si on a
bien suivi l'article 1 supprimé devient
irrecevable et l'article 40 sur les
recevabilités sera déposée par la
présidente de qui déclarera en fait cet
article cet amendement il recevable donc
il ne devrait pas figurer dans le débat
je sais que les insoumis travaillaient
énormément en ce moment il y a eu des
amendements déposés sur une sorte de
contre-attaque parlementaire est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire plus est-ce que
vous allez au fond sortir des pancartes
ou au contraire trouver des moyens de
procédure déjà l'un n'exclut pas l'autre
mais disons qu'il y a deux options qui
sont l'ordre du jour jeudi soit la
présidente de l'Assemblée estime que
dans un parlement moderne des
parlementaires peut faire des
propositions
doivent être examinées d'autant comme
dans le cas présent ou à l’engage pas en
fait de nouvelles charges financières et
par ailleurs même si parce qu'on
rappellera que la plupart des parlements
du monde un parlementaire peut proposer
quelque chose qui coûte de l'argent
c'est quand même l'idée lorsqu'on vote
le budget première option second option
madame Braun Pivet se fait la porte-voix
de l'exécutif c'est-à-dire elle porte la
voie d'Emmanuel Macron madame borne elle
décide d'empêcher l'examen de ce texte
en rendant il recevable l'amendement qui
rétablit donc le vote sur le retour à
son de 2 ans de l'âge de départ à la
retraite auquel cas finalement la
situation est celle d'un péril assez
grand c'est tout simplement une
présidente de l'Assemblée n'est plus en
capacité de défendre liberté
parlementaire par rapport à gouvernement
donc dans cette situation nous on a
quelques amendements qu'on dépose on
tente d'autres formulations pour essayer
de passer l'obstacle de cet article 40
on propose différentes manières de
formuler se rétablissement on espère que
l'institution permettra de les examiner
si elle ne le permet pas et bien écoutez
ça plaît pour une seule chose c'est le
dépassement la Cinquième République et
le fait de ouvrir enfin le débat dans ce
pays sur une sixième république quel
rendez-vous dans les yeux parce que ça
prendra du temps
et la rue parce que il faut que l'espace
public s'empare de la question est-ce
qu'on veut encore de ce régime ou est-ce
qu'il faut avoir une réflexion
collective démocratique sur comment on
peut décider autrement compris bien
compris la stratégie vous avez peur du 8
juin pour terminer
vous avez peur du vote alors non plus je
suis désolé notre journée c'est que
mercredi nous sommes allés en commission
à affronter le vote sur la suppression
de l'article 1 nous l'avons assumé et
nous l'avons gagné j'observe simplement
qu'à chaque fois qu'on vote et que le
vote est défavorable et bien il faut
bordéliser bon ben voilà ok on en prend
acte mais je peux pas laisser dire que
notre président de l'Assemblée nationale
serait conduire dépendant de d'un avis
ou d'un ordre de l'Élysée je suis désolé
elle a déjà prouvé son indépendance ne
serait-ce qu'en Brigant le
perchoirs
dès 9h pour suivre en direct ce débat
qui pourra voilà qui doit avoir lieu on
verra de quelle manière sur cette
proposition de loi Eliott on s'arrête là
merci à vous merci d'être venu débattre
sur la Chaîne Parlementaire vous restez
avec moi Jean-François Kahn dans une
dizaine de minutes elle est partie près
de nos affranchis ce soir le regard sur
l'Europe de Richard Verly qui va
s'arrêter sur la Hongrie de Victor Orban
la crise du logement très alarmante nous
dira fftel et si et si c'était pour un
bien on se pose la question enfin d'un
Bourbon Express ce soir Elsa de quoi
parle-t-on bah vous avez commencé à en
parler Myriam moi je m'installe dans le
perchoir et je me mets dans la tête de
Yaël brune Pivet la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale parfait à tout à
l'heure on nous avons hâte mais en
attendant Jean-François Cannes on va
plonger dans votre livre comment on en
est arrivé là aux éditions de
l'Observatoire c'est le récit d'un échec
collectif celui d'un aveuglement sur la
montée des extrêmes politiques
intellectuel médias tous responsables
ça m'a fait réfléchir et ça m'a fait
beaucoup
rigoler ça des forail et ça il faut le
reconnaître c'est à la fois toujours
aussi pertinent avec de la profondeur
historique mais c'est aussi très piquant
et tout le monde en prend pour son grade
on voit cela dans l'invitation de Maïté
Frémont et on en parle c'est promis
juste après
si on vous invite Jean-François Kahn
c'est parce que vous souhaitez
collectivement nous interpeller avec
cette question qui vous obsède tant
comment en est-on arrivé là ceux-là de
votre titre c'est celui d'un
rassemblement national devenu premier
groupe d'opposition à l'Assemblée
nationale et d'une marine Le Pen aux
portes du pouvoir moi je suis très
inquiet on va voir une éradication de la
gauche républicaine et démocratique une
explosion de la droite républicaine et
démocratique une poussée d'extrême
droite qu'on finit on en est même plus
conscient mais plus de vous en vous
aurez dit ça il y a 10 ans plus de 32%
sur les extrêmes droites on vous aurait
dit ça
alors Jean-François Cannes avec la
liberté de vos 85 ans vous prenez une
nouvelle fois la plume pour nous alerter
sur cette tentation des extrêmes qui
risquent selon vous de conduire à la
guerre civile vous l'ancien journaliste
qui est passé par tous les grands médias
presse écrite et radio vous avez aussi
créé votre propre journal L'Événement du
jeudi puis Marianne 10 ans plus tard pas
question de vous taire quitte à ne pas
plaire dans vos 500 pages toute la
classe politique en prend pour son grade
Jaurès remplacé par Mathilde panot
c'était comme si à Eddy Merckx on avait
substitué un enfant colérique monté sur
un tricycle Éric Ciotti se serait voulu
Jean-Luc Mélenchon de la droite il n'en
sera que le Benoît Hamon
mais surtout dans votre essai vous
fouillez dans votre mémoire pour trouver
les raisons de cette montée de l'extrême
droite en France en 2022 à la
présidentielle seulement 5 millions de
voix c'est par Emmanuel Macron et Marine
Le Pen contre dix millions cinq ans plus
tôt si le cordon sanitaire plie il ne
seront pas totalement alors une question
ce soir Jean-François Kahn avec ses 500
pages ne jouez-vous pas à nous faire
peur
réponse non parce que ce que je dis
c'est que si on continue à jouer au con
oui nous aurons une victoire de Marine
Le Pen extrêmement on n'est pas obligé
de continuer à jouer au con c'est vrai
que je ne vois pas aujourd'hui les
éléments qui me permettent d'espérer
qu'on arrête de jouer au con mais enfin
on peut l'espérer
mon livre c'est pour que ça n'arrive pas
c'est sûr je ne dis pas que ça va
arriver quand même plus de 13 millions
de voix pour Marine Le Pen en 2022 près
de 42% des voix c'est tout simplement
inimaginable même pas 10 ans avant elle
prospère elle progresse sur l'échec de
qui sur le chèque 42% pour les extrêmes
droites les extraits
ce qui est inouï c'est qu'on puisse
avoir des sondages montrant que les
extrêmes droites pourraient faire 42% et
que personne ne se pose la question
c'est pas bien
mais en quoi quelle erreur on a commise
comment on en est arrivé là alors ils
disent les autres c'est Macron c'est la
droite d'accord c'est pas que les autres
peut-être c'est soit aussi
les journalistes alors je l'aurais je
l'ai déjà dit mais j'aurais 50 ans
j'aurais pas écrit ce livre j'aurais pas
osé pourquoi parce que évidemment la
responsabilité des médias de droite et
gauche est énorme parce que c'était eux
qui la signal d'alarme on a ce qui se
passe et inouïe il y a une espèce
d'habitude aujourd'hui de de
valorisation de l'excès outrance de la
violence du mensonge de l'idiotie aussi
franchement je donne tout un chapitre
sur ce qui a été écrit par des
intellectuels au moment du covid ça Yuri
sans dédie aussi ahurissent ces médias
qui se gavent des personnalités très
clivantes du clash et du buzz les
Sandrine
vous dites une connerie extremiste vous
êtes un lendemain à la télé il y a des
médias plus responsables que d'autres
c'est pas à moi de dire je pense qu'ils
sont vous savez en plus je fais une part
de responsabilité
vous avez je parle Canal+ vous avez des
gens qui crient pendant le plus qui
travaillent avec Canal+ qu'on s'est idée
j'étais sceptique moi c'est petit qui
ont fait cette radio leur succès de
cette radio de cette télé puis un type
arrive il est riche il est très très
riche il rachète il dit bon bah très
bien je vire ceux qui sont pas d'accord
avec moi et maintenant vous allez dire
l'inverse mais comment on peut accepter
ça comment accepter que parce qu'on a de
l'argent on prend un journal un média
que des gens ont fait ont imaginé ont
créé avec leur talent et on dit ça va
être l'inverse parce que moi mon argent
permet de dire que ça va être l'inverse
ça c'est le capitalisme dans ce que ça
pire c'est clair vous dites que c'est un
échec collectif bien sûr il y a les
dirigeants mais pas seulement il y a
aussi le débat d'idées les intellectuels
les journalistes au fond c'est vraiment
une responsabilité collective c'est
aussi une forme d'autocrit ce livre
parce que vous Jean-François Cannes on
s'en souvient vous avez cru au
dépassement du clivage gauche-droite
vous avez cru à l'espace au centre vous
avez cru à tout ça et aujourd'hui il est
toujours là Marine Le Pen le dépassement
du non pas du clivage gauche-droite je
pense qu'il a un déplaçable le
dépassement de la gauche tel qu'elle est
devenue et de la droite telle qu'elle
est venue je le pense absolument et je
pense qu'au contraire c'est parce que on
a reculé devant sa dépassement qu'on est
dans une situation des extraits moi vous
savez j'ai fait une expérience
excusez-moi c'est toute la fin du livre
je le publie j'ai fait une expérience
extraordinaire
pour dire ce que je conviens de dire
j'ai trois fois j'ai envoyé une tribune
libre aux filles héros pour dire arrêtez
arrêtez cette surenchère arrêtez d'abord
vous allez faire je l'extrême droite et
puis vous allez tuer la droite trois
fois je fais une tribune libre pour le
monde mais ils m'ont dit ah non pour
leur dire ça la même chose mais si vous
continuez à couvrir les absurdités d'une
certaine gauche les dérives
et les gens qui de lui rendre seront
stupéfaits durant comment on pouvait pas
dire ça on pouvait pas publier ce non
pas que les gens je suis sûr que si vous
l'avez lu vous avez été stupéfait de
vous absolument tout y est tout y est
dans la dans la larme en même temps ce
qui nous arrive la montée des extrêmes
la montée des populismes ça arrive à
toute l'Europe et bien au-delà on le
voit en Italie avec mélonie le brexit au
Royaume-Uni la Hongrie la Pologne donc
Marine Le Pen c'est plus quoi un
symptôme de quoi dans ces pays et
l'effondre d'extrême gauche dans ces
pays c'est la mondialisation qui est
rejetée partout en Europe avec ses excès
sur la question économique et sociale
sur la question culturelle aussi c'est
le refus non oui la mondialisation mais
du caractère néo-capitaliste enfin
néolibak capitaliste néo capitalisme
néolibéral de la mondialisation ça c'est
évident qu'il y a un refus assez général
et puis pour l'extrême gauche vous savez
au Chili au Chili il y a eu un mouvement
social ça ça fait réfléchir sur ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui il y a un mouvement
social énorme
du coup le gouvernement qui était de
droite le président de droite a dû
démissionner
aux nouvelles élections un président de
gauche est élu et dit on va faire une
nouvelle constitution parce que
l'ancienne c'était celle de Pinochet et
on vote pour qui va participer à la
commission qui va penser cette
constitution on vote et l'extrême gauche
qui se présente comme des indépendants
donc les gens savent pas que c'est
extrêmement beau je suis votre elle est
majoritaire dans dans la commission il
faut une constitution qui est exactement
la institution que réclame Mélenchon
aujourd'hui pour remplacer ces gammes
publics te dire une constitution
anarchisante pour l'idée des gens
qu'est-ce qui se passe ta fouille
réfléchir qu'est-ce qui se passe il faut
un référendum pour savoir s'ils
acceptent cette constitution refuser à
65%. et ensuite ah bon ben alors il faut
une nouvelle commission vote c'était il
y a deux mois
raz-de-marée d'extrême droite
il ne regarde pas ses réalités l'extrême
gauche nourrit
pas par principe mais aujourd'hui vous
expliquer pour vous au fond elles sont
complices c'est les deux faces d'une
même pièce il y a des convergences entre
les extrêmes droites et les extrêmes
gauches expliquez-nous ça je crois
qu'hier du temps du stabilis on aurait
dit il y a une complicité objective bon
mais non il y a pas de compliqué
objective je pensais pas voulu c'est pas
calculé peut-être par une minorité mais
mais il y a en effet à partir du moment
ou une fraction de l'extrême gauche
emploi des moyens qui étaient la
spécificité de l'extrême droite elle
était certaine forme de violence par
exemple ou bien s'attaquer aux domicile
d'un certain nombre de gens qu'on peut
voter comme vous le souhaitiez ils n'ont
pas voté ils ont voté de façon qui me
dérange
j'attaque leur permanence j'attaque bon
par exemple le fait de mettre la race au
centre de toutes les discussions moi
quand il y a 20 ans la gauche comment
dirait excluait qu'on puisse se
référence à la race
aujourd'hui on ne parle que de ça il y a
une référence continue à la religion à
la race aux gens identité c'était
l'extrême droite c'était la spécialité
d'extrême droite
des vrais similitudes entre les deux
pour vous j'en mets Jean-Luc Mélenchon
Marine Le Pen moi je suis ceux qui
pensent qu'il y a pas de que c'est pas
la même essence mais oui on a vu
aujourd'hui à l'extrême gauche y compris
l'expérience intellectuel on a vu
fleurir refleurir des discours qui
naturellement rappelle ceux qui étaient
la spécificité d'extrême droite alors
vous parlez beaucoup des extrêmes c'est
important au pluriel les extrêmes
droites aussi vous parlez d'Éric Zemmour
vous parlez de Marine Le Pen elle est
d'extrême droite Marine Le Pen elle
récuse
il y a aussi les évolutions moi je
connais bien Zemmour il a même fait des
chroniques dans Marianne au début
l'intérêt que ça soit lui que ça soit
Élisabeth Lévy que ça soit
de véhicules le type du Figaro qu'est-ce
qui les a fait évoluer extrémisé comme
ça ils étaient pas comme ça ils étaient
très aimés que de véhicules ça c'est
intéressant qu'est-ce qui a fait qui
s'est radicalisation qu'est-ce qu'il a
fait l'analyser ben je pense que c'est
c'est en effet une évolution une
droiteisation de la société qui et puis
les erreurs il faut et puis les erreurs
de la gauche il y a un type au Figaro ça
me fait marrer parce que dans ce que
entre nous les un journal comme le monde
est un très bon journal et le Figaro
reste un très bon journal mais leur
rubrique débat enfin la rubrique débat
ça doit être la rubrique on fait
discuter des gens qui sont pas d'accord
qui des dialogue avec la droite dure et
l'autre c'est l'extrême gauche qui
dialogue avec la gauche dure soi-même
peut-être une dernière question vous
avez tout un chapitre sur la comparaison
avec les années 30 vous savez c'est un
peu le point Godwin de toujours aller
chercher des des cadres historiques pour
avoir des repères vous dites que Marine
Le Pen puisse plutôt dans ce fascisme
originel des années 20 que vous voulez
vous dire exactement elle est pertinente
cette cette référence ou pas pour
terminer je le dis dans le livre parce
que je monte pourquoi oralement je ne le
dis pas pourquoi parce que les gens ne
comprennent mal je crois pas du tout que
que Marine Le Pen est anti républicain
je pense que les républicaines je pense
en plus que les pas du tout antisémite
je pense qu'elle est pas une menace en
soi pour la démocratie il serait pas une
dictature je pense que son arrivée au
pouvoir créerait un climat de guerre
civile parce que ça encouragerait
l'extrémisme inverse
certains à l'extrême gauche c'est ce que
vous laissez entendre aller jusque là
mais ce qui est vrai c'est que ce
qu'elle a compris c'est sa force que l'a
fait confluer des revendications
classiques de l'extrême droite tout le
sur la sécurité des migrations d'Alban
avec des revendications qui venaient
plutôt de l'extrême gauche de remise en
cause du capitalisme et sincère
d'ailleurs chez elle je crois
ça rappelle en effet mais les gens l'ont
oublié ce qui était le fascisme des
années 20 en Italie la force de
Mussolini qui venait de l'extrême gauche
vous signale c'était d'avoir fait cette
convergence entre ces deux ces deux
sentiments en tout cas c'est passionnant
de vous entendre oralement mais aussi de
vous lire parce que je le disais il y a
énormément de références historiques
pour essayer de comprendre le temps
présent et les dangers surtout sur la
musique parce que
l'extrémisme a tué également
il faut pas les laisser gagner dans ces
cas-là parce que la musique c'est trop
important on continue Jean-François Kahn
vous restez avec moi comment on en est
arrivé là aux éditions d'observatoire
allez c'est l'heure d'accueillir les
affranchis pour leur parti pris ils vont
vous faire réagir Jean-François canon
les accueille tout de suite
installez-vous
de libération qui va nous parler
logement la crise est profonde crise de
l'offre mais aussi crise de la demande
va voir ça dans un instant Richard verni
que j'espère en pleine forme du
quotidien Blic regards européen préparé
vos parties pris parce qu'on commence
comme chaque soir par bonbon Express
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée nous
est raconté ce soir par Elsa bonsoir
Elsa bonsoir je vous raconte ce soir
l'histoire d'une présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale scrutée et attendu
au tournant je vous explique je
rembobine ce matin j'étais à l'Assemblée
nationale et the place to be maintenant
c'est la conférence de presse du groupe
liotte regardez une salle bondée je le
rappelle à ceux qui ne connaissent pas
encore ce groupe l'iode pour liberté
indépendant outre-mer et territoire
c'est un groupe hétéroclite à l'origine
d'une proposition de loi pour abroger la
réforme des retraites et ce matin ils
avaient un message à faire passer
écoutez à qui
nous regardons avec beaucoup de sérieux
les décisions qui seront prises par la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale à la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
puisque la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale va défendre notre institution
ou la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale la président de la nationale
la présidente nationale va être face à
une décision redoutable il les en appel
vous avez compris
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
alors pourquoi c'est un peu technique
mais la semaine dernière en commission
des affaires sociales dans un climat
tendu l'article 1 il a été supprimé
sorti par la porte il revient par la
fenêtre mais cette fois sous forme
d'amendements et c'est vraiment
différent puisque sur les amendements la
présidente de l'Assemblée est bien elle
a le pouvoir de les déclarer ircevable
en lieu et place du président de la
commission des finances Éric Coquerel
Éric Coquerel on l'a vu tout à l'heure
celle des quêtes colonnes il le sait il
y a El brun Pivet elle a déjà dit
qu'elle prendrait ses responsabilités
ça va inévitablement la placer là où
manifestement elle voulait pas être
c'est à dire du côté de ceux qui depuis
le début sans même aucun argument
demande que cette PPL soit irrecevable
tout simplement parce qu'ils ont peur du
vote voilà parce que selon certains dans
l'opposition et bien elle brune Pivet
agirait contre son propre gré oui à
l'insu de son plein gré dans la majorité
et dans les oppositions c'est ce qu'on
dit la présidente aurait reçu des
pressions de l'exécutif pour débrancher
la proposition de loi il y a le bon
Pivet elle a d'ailleurs été interpellé à
ce sujet dans l'hémicycle tout à l'heure
lors de la séance de questions au
gouvernement
je m'adressais à la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale madame Pivet je
vous invite à ne pas écouter ce
gouvernement qui mène le pays droit dans
le mur et à défendre l'Assemblée
nationale le 8 juin lors de l'examen du
texte du groupe yote pour aborder la
réforme je vous indique madame la
députée que lorsque je préside les
questions au Gouvernement il est d'usage
que je ne prenne pas par au débat je
vous remercie de ne pas m'interpeller
alors elle a pas répondu dans
l'hémicycle on coulisse elle réfute
avoir subi des pressions mais ce qui est
sûr c'est que la présidente en prenant
cette décision ou pas même si il y a
plus vraiment de suspense elle va
s'exposer s'exposer à d'éventuelles
représailles des oppositions
est-ce que si elle utilise l'article 40
vous allez lui en vouloir et ce que vous
lui ferez un peu payer alors je veux pas
le dire comme ça mais on va lui en
vouloir oui parce qu'elle est là pour
préserver les droits du Parlement et qui
plus est les droits de l'opposition la
Présidente c'est quelqu'un qui est
au-dessus de la mêlée elle est pas
présidente d'un parti mais c'est pas une
question de sentiment c'est une question
de d'actes politiques ce geste s'il est
posé c'est un geste contre le Parlement
et contre la démocratie donc nous ne
pouvons pas l'accepter effectivement je
crois que ça va abîmer notre capacité à
travailler ensemble voilà pour les
positions des uns et des autres alors
très concrètement si la présidente
déclare irrecevable et bien cette
amendement qu'est-ce qui se passe alors
ce qui est à peu près sûr c'est qu'on
parlera quand même de cette proposition
de loi jeudi à 9 heures dans l'hémicycle
puisque le groupe liote va la maintenir
il va garder une tribune de quelques
heures politiques pour dénoncer les
choix du gouvernement et de la majorité
après il peut retirer son texte et
passer à autre chose ou alors et vous
l'avez vu dans votre sans débats les
oppositions et bien ils recherchent
toutes les petites portes des
amendements rédigées de telle façon à ce
qu'on fixe un objectif un principe ce
qu'ils veulent c'est essayer de
provoquer un vote gagner une petite
victoire politique on parle aussi d'une
motion de censure ce qui est sûr c'est
que la bataille des retraites elle est
pas finie à l'Assemblée nationale merci
beaucoup Elsa c'était limpide
rendez-vous donc jeudi 9h sur LCP pour
suivre en direct ce qui va se passer sur
cette proposition de loi dans l'émission
vous vouliez revenir sur la crise du
logement c'est une crise grave et
profonde d'ailleurs tous les
professionnels ont des mots très très
fort pour la qualifier c'est une crise à
la fois de l'offre pas assez de
logements en construction mais c'est
aussi une crise de la demande qui vient
se sur Ajouter ces nouveaux depuis
l'automne la remontée des taux d'intérêt
a eu pour effet de renchérir le taux du
crédit le coût du crédit parce qu'ils
sont passés de 1 à 3% c'est taux
d'intérêt et les banques en plus sont
devenues très frileuses ce qui se
traduit par une chute quand même de 40%
de la production de crédit immobilier
résultat dans le neuf les promoteurs se
retrouvent avec des milliers de
programmes sur les bras parce que en
gros il y a pas il y a plus d'acheteurs
donc c'est toute la filière du BTP c'est
quand même 1,4 millions d'emplois qui
souffrent et comme on dit quand le
bâtiment va tout va voilà donc et à
l'inverse c'est pourquoi donc hier la
première ministre Elisabeth borne a
dévoilé une série de mesures d'urgence
en clôture du CNR logement un conseil
national de la refondation mais c'est
peu de dire qu'elles ont vraiment déçu
les acteurs pourquoi dans le cadre de ce
CNR depuis six mois 200 personnes ont
planché et ils sont parvenus à des
consensus et aussi à des propositions
mais quasiment aucune n'a été retenu
alors la réaction était très virulente
notamment la Fédération française du
bâtiment la Fédération des promoteurs
immobiliers la Fédération nationale de
l'immobilier enfin dans un communiqué
commun au ton vraiment cinglant on dit
que le secteur était méprisé et ils ont
demandé
à rencontrer en urgence les présidents
des groupes parlementaires sous-entendus
il y a plus rien attendre de ce
gouvernement alors beaucoup de PPL à
l'assemblée de proposition de loi sur le
logement donc rendez-vous à l'Assemblée
alors pourquoi cette colère alors il y a
deux choses il y a la suppression de la
niche fiscale Pinel qui est soutenait
l'investissement locatif et aussi le
resserrement du prêt à taux zéro alors
qu'il va certes prolongé jusqu'en 2027
c'est très important pour l'accès à la
propriété mais qui va plus être qui va
être recalibré il sera plus mobilisable
pour l'achat d'une maison individuelle
et comme me l'a expliqué un promoteur
rien qu'avec ces deux mesures l'État va
faire 2 milliards d'euros d'économies à
peu près c'est vraiment pas le moment on
peut dire d'autant que le logement lui
rapporte en net 52 milliards d'euros si
on prend la différence entre les
recettes fiscales du logement c'est 90
milliards énormes et les dépenses qui
sont 38 52 et mon promoteur d'ajouter
bah au final c'est encore Bercy qui a eu
le dernier mot il y a quand même l'air
sur Olivier Klein on va dire sur le
ministre du Logement il y a des raisons
quand même un peu d'espérer de tout ça
ou pas alors oui parce que cette hausse
des taux d'intérêt de façon assez
mécanique devrait conduire à une des
prix de vente des logements le sing tank
Terranova fait les calculs il pense que
les prix devraient baisser de l'ordre de
20% dans l'ancien de 10% dans le neuf ah
oui c'est énorme c'est un pectine ils
ont été multipliés par trois en France
et même par trois et demi à Paris donc
bonne nouvelle on peut on peut se dire
qu'on va acheter si vous voulez
l'augmentation des prix de l'immobilier
ça a été vraiment le principal moteur de
l'accroissement des inégalités de
patrimoine et aussi des inégalités
sociales et là pour une fois c'est les
plus jeunes et les moins favorisés qui
vont sortir gagnant et non pas les
boomers
les plus riches et surtout leurs
héritiers donc de ce point de vue on
peut dire vive la crise merci beaucoup
pour ce parti pris tout en contradiction
Richard on termine avec vous et je suis
sûr que ça va vous intéresser Richard
werli du quotidien suisse blig veut nous
alerter sur une présidence que pourrait
prendre la Hongrie c'est ça présidente
de Victor Orban de l'Union européenne à
Bruxelles gros malaise c'est ça
effectivement ce cher Victor urban alors
vous savez il y a deux manières de le
considérer je crois que c'est important
de le rappeler le Premier ministre
hongrois il a été très nettement rayu en
avril 2022 après la victoire au
législatif de son parti le fidège donc
la première manière de le voir c'est de
voir en lui un dirigeant soucieux de son
pays qui est un produit de son histoire
et qui est toujours attaché à ce rêve
d'une Hongrie quasi neutre entre
l'Europe de l'Ouest et la Russie alors
ça peut énerver ça peut sembler
scandaleux compte tenu de l'ampleur de
l'agression de Vladimir Poutine mais
après tout une majorité de Hongrois
semble penser comme lui dans un pays où
rappelons-le les médias les juges sont
étroitement contrôlés et où
l'approvisionnement énergétique dépend
presque entièrement de Moscou mais il y
a une autre manière de voir Orban et
c'est de ça dont je voulais parler c'est
là où rien ne va plus car après avoir
traîné les pieds et obtenu des
dérogations pour continuer à acheter du
gaz russe le Premier ministre hongrois
s'oppose aujourd'hui un nouveau paquet
de sanctions européennes contre la
Russie ce sera le 11e il s'oppose aussi
au remboursement par l'Union européenne
des achats d'armes pour l'Ukraine et à
une nouvelle tranche d'aide militaire
bref le dissident Orban est devenu le
bloqueur en chef évidemment ça n'est pas
acceptable pour les Européens alors
absolument et c'est bien pour ça que la
semaine dernière vous parliez d'une
présidence et bien les députés européens
ont voté une résolution qui demande le
report de la présidence tournante
hongroise de l'Union vous savez c'est 6
mois pendant lesquels un pays préside
l'Union la France est il n'y a pas si
longtemps elle devait avoir lieu elle
devrait pardon avoir lieu au second
semestre 2024 et bien les députés
veulent que ce soit repousser et ça je
crois que c'est tout à fait significatif
comment accepter en effet que l'Union
soit présidé par un Premier ministre qui
fait tout pour entraver son affirmation
de puissance et pour permettre à Poutine
de fait de gagner du temps lorsque je
regrette c'est que cette résolution elle
a pas du tout été diffusée largement à
Budapest même pas par la Délégation de
la Commission européenne car pourtant il
faudrait le dire on croit il faudrait
rappeler par exemple que 28 milliards
d'euros pour une population de 10
millions d'habitants sont actuellement
retenus par Bruxelles en raison des
attentes à l'état de droit donc Léon
droit peuvent choisir de se rapprocher
de la Russie mais ce ne peuvent pas s'y
prendre le reste de l'Union en otage
vous savez qu'à Bratislava Emmanuel
Macron a parlé d'une Europe à plusieurs
vitesses et bien c'est le moment de
l'enclencher et de marginaliser Victor
Hormann ce n'est plus seulement
politiquement logique c'est
institutionnellement indispensable merci
beaucoup on a raison de durcir le ton
avec avec Orban il faut carrément
peut-être même sortir de l'Union j'ai
peur de ce que allez
je trouve ça on nous avait annoncé on
parlait des médias pour de bonnes
raisons vous avez annoncé aux dernières
élections qu'il allait
perdre la majorité j'étais très content
sauf que c'était pas vrai après on nous
a annoncé que la droite polonaise qui
est insupportable elle est perd des
élections j'étais ravi et c'était pas
vrai après dans un annoncé qu'il y avait
un mécontentement en Russie qu'elle est
balayée Poutine j'étais mais
enthousiaste
Erdogan tout le monde nous annonçait
qu'il allait perdre la majorité etc ah
j'étais au jour en joie mais c'était pas
vrai faut arrêter faut regarder la
réalité en face
[Musique]